[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la l'édition 2023 du CES de Las
Vegas se vient de se clôturer elle a
laissé une part large aux automobiles et
à cette obligation le PDG de stellantis
Carlos Tavares a lancé une nouvelle
charge charge contre le niveau du prix
extrêmement bas des véhicules chinois
zéro émission qui met en péril
l'industrie européenne et cette
industrie pour le seul territoire
national c'est 210 000 emplois directs
auxquels il convient d'ajouter tous les
emplois indirects si j'en crois les
objectifs affichés par trois
constructeurs chinois pour les cités
gélier sec et gruth wall à E3 ils
envisagent d'importer un million de
véhicules sur les territoires européens
d'ici trois ans ils sont déjà en train
de construire le système de distribution
qui leur permettra d'atteindre cet
objectif alors certes sur le territoire
national les véhicules électriques
progressent plus que 46%
d'immatriculation en 2021 mais 80% de
ces véhicules sont importés et la presse
ne s'y trompe pas elle écrit d'ailleurs
le loup chinois est dans la bergerie en
effet la Chine c'est 50% de la valeur
totale d'un véhicule électrique c'est
75% de la chaîne de valeur des batteries
c'est 90% des moteurs électriques
produits dans le monde et face à tout ça
l'industrie européenne est en très
grande difficulté elle ne parvient même
plus à pénétrer le marché chinois alors
dans cette bataille qui vient de
commencer monsieur le ministre quels
sont nos armes avez-vous choisi une
guerre de position et donc de continuer
à subir les assauts chinois ou
entendez-vous sortir de notre tranchée
et lancer une guerre de mouvement